Amen.
Donc c'est que nous avons déjà couvert en considérant la confession artiste et foi,
notamment les chapitres sur la création.
Le premier paragraphe, c'est celui sur lequel on a fait toutes les considérations
sur la relation, les rapports entre la Bible et la science.
Et la vérité la plus importante à saisir,
c'est que l'interprétation littérale des Genèses est une question confessionnelle.
Et l'opposition plus récente à une interprétation littérale
est vraiment quelque chose qui sort complètement du cadre de la tradition d'interprétation publique
et des confessions des fois chrétiennes.
C'est clairement une réaction sous pression et on essaie de s'adapter quelque part
à ce qui a réclamé comme science mais qui ne passe des théories
et des théories qui ne sont pas très bien basées
et qui a conduit certains théologiens à corrompre et compromettre
les principes d'interprétation biblique.
Donc ce sont des implications directes aux critères d'interprétation biblique.
Et si c'est la Bible elle-même qui doit nous enseigner à interpréter la Bible
et si les auteurs bibliques sont trouvés dans les Écritures interprètes littéralement Genès,
c'est un grand compromis.
Donc dans un échange récent, très récent, une question m'a été posée,
si je voyais par exemple des Églises qui commettent l'erreur d'avoir des femmes pasteurs
ne sont pas en train de commettre des erreurs plus graves
que de ne pas croire par exemple aux six jours littéraux de la création.
Et donc bien qu'il y ait dans la surface, on ait plutôt l'impression,
c'est beaucoup plus clair et évident parfois,
des pensées que d'avoir des femmes pasteurs,
c'est un attaque contre la complémentarité biblique explicite
et les principes bibliques sont très clairs pour dire
qui doit exercer les rôles des pasteurards à l'Église
et toutes ces implications pour l'instructur familiale de l'Église.
Donc c'est une erreur très grave et clairement contraire
à ce qui est clair et explicite dans la Bible.
Le problème c'est que même cette erreur-là est une conséquence
d'un mauvais traitement des Écritures
qui est interlié et peut avoir aussi son origine
dans tous les changements même culturels et sociaux
qui sont conséquences d'un changement des perspectives
par rapport à ce qu'il y a à l'homme en tant qu'une créature divine.
Et nous en tant que chrétiens, quand on considère où trouver la base biblique
pour défendre ce qu'est l'homme, ce qu'est la femme, pour défendre la complémentarité
et nous devons revenir clairement à Genèse chapitre 1
par une interprétation littérale car Dieu a créé l'homme à son image,
homme et femme, il les a créés.
Donc des fois, quand on regarde dans la surface,
on ne prend pas en considération le fait que cette attitude biblique
envers la Bible qui devient flux libéral
où nous nous permettons d'avoir des flexibilités
là où la Bible n'a pas de flexibilité pour interpréter elle-même les textes bibliques,
c'est une attitude envers la parole des dieux
qui développe une espèce de méfiance
et qui c'est dans les droits d'être flexibles
où les auteurs bibliques ne nous permettent pas d'être flexibles.
Et c'est d'avoir, on va dire comme ça,
c'est d'avoir courbé à ces pressions
qui vont toutes dans les mêmes directions
et qui sont interliées
et qui finissent pour provoquer toute la révélation sexuelle, etc.
mais qui sont un attaque à la base originale
du récit biblique de la création de l'humanité.
Et donc, qu'est-ce qu'on devrait considérer
comme plus grave en tant qu'erreur ?
À mon avis, au moins on peut se dire
qu'il y a par un lien des causes et conséquences,
des causes et effets,
et par une question des fondaments basiques bibliques
et par une comparaison claire
entre l'explicité dont la Bible nous présente,
la vérité avec clarté dans la Bible elle-même.
Les deux choses démontrent une attitude
d'insoumission à la parole des dieux.
Et donc, les deux choses sont très graves.
Et dans ma perception,
quelque part, une des racines
de toutes ces mauvaises doctrines
et pratiques dans l'Église même,
elle se trouve plutôt comme racine
dans les problèmes de ne pas interpréter
de manière littérale,
Genèse, de manière historique.
Le terme Genèse signifie histoire.
Et nous devrions l'interpréter comme tel.
Et donc, voilà pourquoi
les six jours de création,
c'est presque une obligation
par les ménotiques bibliques,
de croire,
car tous les auteurs bibliques,
y compris les Christ,
ont traité Genèse comme histoire littérale.
Et donc, à partir de là,
je vous lance la question.
On a aussi considéré,
non seulement l'implication
envers la complémentarité des genres,
l'identité des genres,
comme on dit aujourd'hui,
mais sur l'ensemble de l'anthropologie,
sur l'ensemble de la sociologie,
de la philosophie,
de la psychologie.
Donc, aujourd'hui aussi,
les chrétiens, les émangéliques
sont très vulnérables à la psychologie.
Et on oublie, en fait,
qu'elle est présupposée
de la psychologie moderne,
la psychanalyse, par exemple,
sont à l'opposé
de la perspective biblique
de l'origine de l'homme.
Donc, qui serait le plus capable
à discerner
quelles sont les maladies psychologiques,
c'est-à-dire de l'âme humaine,
les maladies émotionnelles même de l'homme,
spirituelles de l'homme,
notamment, c'est lorsqu'on a
l'anthropologie biblique
qui nous est présentée
et que nous comprenons
quels sont les démons
les plus profonds de l'homme,
comment régler ces problématiques,
quelle est la crise fondamentale de l'homme.
Et parfois, on est en train
de faire usage
des médicaments
ou des traitements
qui ne font qu'é supprimer les symptômes,
alléger les symptômes,
ne pas nous permettre
de sentir les symptômes
d'une maladie beaucoup plus radicale
qui a à voir
avec ce qui nous sommes
en tant que créé par Dieu
et ce qui nous ne pouvons qu'é régler
lorsque nous revenons à Dieu.
Et donc,
toute attitude
de l'Église,
de la Bible,
des chrétiens
qui passent à faire
plus confiance
à des traitements
qui sont originaires
d'une perspective
à propos de l'homme
qui ne peut pas connaître
l'homme
tel qu'il est
car ils ne prennent pas
en considération
ce que l'homme est
selon la Bible,
selon les créateurs.
Et donc,
c'est très important pour nous,
c'est pas pour ne pas reconnaître
que certaines intercessions
sont possibles
et des traitements
plus objectifs,
plus mécaniques,
plus comportamentaux
puissent être considérés,
mais c'est pour nous rappeler
en fait
qu'il y a
la plus grande capacité
de nous enseigner
ce qu'est l'homme
et comment les traiter,
c'est la parole de Dieu
elle-même
et notamment par la considération
de l'anthropologie biblique,
c'est qu'on considère
quand on considère
Genèse
de manière littérale.
Donc,
c'est l'éthème
ou l'un des thèmes centrales,
donc l'éthème central
de la Bible,
c'est Dieu lui-même,
mais c'est notamment
Dieu venant
à la recherche
de son peuple
ou Dieu venant
à secourir
l'être humain,
sauver l'être humain
de ces maladies
d'âme,
spirituelles.
Et donc,
quelque part,
la Bible commence
par cette réalité
et quelques textes
capitaux,
donc toute la parole
de Dieu,
retournent à cette conception
de l'image
de Dieu dans l'homme.
Donc,
notre origine,
les centres
de la rédemption,
c'est de nous référer
à l'image de Dieu
comme on était un jour
et cette relation
avec Dieu.
Donc,
la...
!
c'est intéressant, nous voyons que la base biblique pour, dans cette période, démontrer les principes pour la peine capitale, c'est une base perpétuelle, c'est une base qui n'est pas basée sur la culture.
Et la base, c'est le fait que Dieu a créé l'homme à son image.
Et donc, même après la chute, c'est lui qui est interdit de répandre les saints avec la menace d'avoir nos vies enlevées, car l'homme a été fait à l'image de Dieu.
!
Et Jacques, décrivant l'ensemble de l'humanité, il dit, nous bénissons Dieu le Père et nous maudissons les hommes faits à l'image de Dieu.
Et donc là, c'est une considération, même l'homme dans sa condition, des chutes en tant qu'image de Dieu.
Paul va prêcher aux Athéniens en disant, c'est une race des dieux.
Même les Athéniens perdus, ils reconnaînaient qu'ils étaient images des dieux.
Et donc, les déclarations préalables pour notre intérêt.
La première, c'est de se demander s'il y a des distinctions, des différences entre ces deux termes, images et rassemblances.
Donc, il y a des distinctions, mais pas des différences.
À plusieurs reprises, ils sont présentés comme synonymes.
Mais si vous voulez avoir une légère distinction entre eux, une a plus les poids des copies, d'une copie, et l'autre a plus l'idée des représentativités.
Et ça, c'est intéressant, car l'être humain, il est en soi quelque part une copie des dieux, une image des dieux.
Il a été fait similairement à Dieu, mais il a été aussi investi quelque part des fonctionnalités ou d'une espèce d'autorité déléguée à l'homme, d'être les représentants des dieux dans l'univers.
Donc, images, rassemblances, selon les textes originaux, la légère distinction est celle-là.
Encore une qui se porte plus vers ce qu'il est en tant qu'image des dieux, et l'autre qui semble donner plutôt l'idée de sa position, qui doit représenter Dieu pour toute la création.
Donc, rassemblances, c'est plutôt un suivant, un motif, une forme, un modèle.
Et quand on va dans l'Ancien Testament, par exemple, on a déjà cité Nabucodonosor qui faisait des statues qui devraient étendre quelque part, par sa représentativité, la statue.
Elle représentait son règne là où elle était.
Et donc, voilà pourquoi l'homme a été créé à l'image et à la rassemblance des dieux.
Donc, l'idée, comme 2 Corinthiens 3 nous présente, c'est l'idée d'un miroir.
Et je pense que le plus on avance dans notre compréhension de l'image des dieux, le plus, et c'est pour ça que je voulais commencer par là,
le plus on peut exploiter cette illustration des miroirs de manière très intéressante.
Donc, déjà, il y a une espèce de contemplation requise, surtout quand on contemple la manière dont l'Écritiste continuera d'être formé en nous.
Nous serons renouvelés à l'image des dieux, centrés sur Christ, donc à l'image du Christ, par la contemplation des gloires en gloire.
Donc, pour que nous soyons l'image des dieux, avant tout, on doit être quelque part devant Dieu.
Vous êtes avec moi ? C'est un reflet d'une contemplation.
Ça parle du fait que nous avons été créés, comme les catéchismes le disent, pour glorifier Dieu en prenant plaisir en lui et prendre plaisir en lui.
Et c'est de cette manière qu'on glorifie Dieu.
On fait un reflet de la gloire des dieux à partir du moment où nous nous satisfaisons dans la contemplation des dieux, déjà.
Et c'est comme si cela énergiserait toutes les capacités que nous avons pour refléter l'image des dieux, pour représenter Dieu.
Et donc là, à l'essence, il y a cette relation.
Car Dieu, lorsqu'il a créé l'homme, les privilèges particuliers qu'il avait en tant qu'image des dieux,
c'était la réjouissance, comme les trois personnes de la Trinité ont, dans cette relation d'amour entre trinitaires,
cette relation des béatitudes, d'être les dieux bienheureux qui prend plaisir en lui-même par ses interactions intradivines.
Et nous, en fait, étant créés à l'image des dieux, l'attribut le plus glorieux qu'on a en tant qu'image des dieux,
c'est la réjouissance des dieux.
La réjouissance de la relation des dieux.
Ce qui était vécu, non seulement de manière indirecte par la création des dieux,
mais qui était vécu dans la virée de tous les jours.
On dit ça en français, la virée, on peut dire ça, non ?
La virée, non.
Car les termes en portugais, ça fait quelque chose comme ça.
La fin de chaque jour, quand un jour va tourner.
Voilà, les changements de chaque jour.
Et particulièrement les sabbats qui étaient un jour sous sept pour l'adoration, relation intentionnelle.
Mais des manières à penser au but de l'homme en tant qu'image des dieux,
c'est donc d'avoir la capacité de refléter Dieu en ayant les privilèges d'intimité avec Dieu.
OK ?
Et donc, il y a aussi la notion non seulement du miroir.
Parfait, si je suis devant une image, si je suis en train de contempler Dieu,
même si je suis arrêté quelque part, l'image, elle préserve les attributs de celui devant qui elle est.
Donc, pour nous, par exemple, on a été créé, même si on est arrêté sans rien faire,
nous avons des attributs, des capacités qui sont les capacités que Dieu seul a.
Et donc, c'est être image de Dieu avant de faire quelque chose.
OK ?
Donc, contempler Dieu, OK ?
Ensuite, avoir des attributs qui Dieu a aussi, donc la moralité, la conscience, etc.
Mais aussi la capacité d'agir, de faire des œuvres, etc.
Et donc, si je suis arrêté devant le miroir, l'image s'est arrêtée.
Mais il y a aussi la notion d'agir ou de représenter.
Donc, à partir du moment où Dieu bouge, si on peut dire comme ça,
on va chercher à bouger selon Dieu.
Par exemple, Dieu va prendre l'homme, va les quitter dès là où il l'avait créé, dans un lieu de l'univers,
et va les placer dans un jardin où Dieu lui-même récultivait.
Dieu, il a laissé un motif de comment il voulait que l'homme, il reproduise les choses.
Il va étendre ses jardins en ayant contemplé la manière de Dieu d'agir.
Et il va inviter Adam d'abord à aller nommer les animaux.
Donc, il va reproduire quelque part ce que Dieu avait déjà fait et laissé comme modèle.
Et donc, c'est d'imiter Dieu en faisant ce que Dieu fait à la manière de Dieu pour plaire Dieu.
Donc, il a cette notion d'être, image des dieux.
Mais il y a aussi cette notion de représenter.
Donc, il y a la notion d'être, de se satisfaire.
Il y a la notion de notre signification, de notre importance en tant qu'image des dieux.
Mais il y a aussi la notion d'obéissance, de responsabilité et rédivabilité.
Ce qui était très plaisant pour nous, car on faisait les œuvres des dieux, selon Dieu, avec perfection.
Et on pourrait rencontrer Dieu les samedis avec la joie d'avoir bien travaillé.
OK ? Vous êtes avec moi ?
Donc, il y a cette idée du miroir.
Elle peut nous aider à garder ses aspects principaux, qu'on verra avec plus de précision à la fin.
Donc, aimer, obéir Dieu, manifester Dieu et représenter Dieu, rendre Dieu accessible à la création.
C'était la représentation des dieux que l'homme devrait porter.
Donc là, pour enrichir notre convention d'image et représentation, rassemblance.
Ensuite, ce terme est utilisé avant et après la chute.
Ça, c'est très important, car plusieurs semblent vouloir définir strictement l'image des dieux,
tout simplement comme l'état original d'Adam.
Et donc, pour plus que la perfection originale qui a été perdue,
elle avait cette capacité parfaite d'être image des dieux.
La perfection, elle a été perdue.
La chute, elle a radicalement corrompu la capacité de l'homme de représenter Dieu,
de bien représenter Dieu.
Mais elle n'a pas supprimé totalement l'image des dieux dans l'homme.
Donc, l'illustration des lois de l'homme, c'est de contempler un être au moins perdu,
comme si c'était ces ruines des châteaux qu'on voit.
Donc, on voit parfois des remparts quand on fait des voyages par la France.
Et nous voyons quelques ruines, quelques restes d'un château.
Donc, quelque part, on peut dire, on ne voit pas toute la gloire de ces châteaux,
mais nous avons quelque part l'évidence des restes de cette gloire.
Et donc, voilà, pour plus qu'un être humain soit incapable aujourd'hui
de faire les biens spirituels, de faire les biens parfaits pour la gloire de Dieu,
pour que ça soit acceptable à Dieu,
il reste quand même complètement différent des animaux
et a la capacité de faire quelques bonnes œuvres,
voilà, partiellement corrompues, mais aussi légitimes.
Donc, l'être humain est capable de faire des poèmes,
est capable de développer de la médecine,
est capable, voilà, de développer parfois des lois justes.
Et donc, par là, nous voyons les restes de l'image de Dieu dans l'homme.
Donc, après la régénération,
l'image de Dieu, elle est radicalement restaurée.
Ok ?
Donc, nous, en tant que chrétiens, nés de nouveau,
nous avons l'image des dieux radicalement restaurée en nous
avec un potentiel de progresser dans la restauration de cette image
qui est les non-convertis, non pas.
Ok ?
Donc, la régénération, elle restaure radicalement,
mais pas totalement encore l'image des dieux en nous.
Et la permanence de l'aspect sacré de l'image des dieux dans l'homme,
c'est la base de la dignité humaine.
Donc, nous ne pourrions jamais parler des droits des hommes
si la France n'avait pas un héritage chrétien,
juif chrétien,
qui a communiqué, qui a passé ses bâtons.
Donc, on réclame que les droits des hommes,
c'est les produits de l'humanisme.
On va même identifier les symboles des francs-maçons, là, dans les documents,
mais la réalité, c'est que la culture française
qui a pu développer les droits des hommes
ne peut pas supprimer l'héritage juif chrétien
sur lequel elle a été fondée.
Et donc, la réalité, c'est que c'est impossible
de parler des droits des hommes,
de l'aspect sacré de la vie humaine,
si nous n'avons pas la notion de l'image des dieux dans l'homme.
C'est ce qui fait l'aspect sacré de la vie,
c'est l'image des dieux dans l'homme.
Et donc, voilà pourquoi
la destruction d'un abordage littéral
des jeunesses
a un impact jusqu'à l'avortement.
Vous voyez ?
On commence à vider l'être humain
de sa signification.
Si la noblesse de l'homme
dépend tout simplement de la complexité
de son développement intellectuel,
par exemple,
car c'est les voies de l'évolution,
si avant cela,
il ne présente pas la noblesse
d'un être plus complexe, plus intelligent,
donc on peut utiliser des excuses
pour supprimer une vie humaine.
Mais la réalité, c'est que selon Dieu,
l'homme, avec sa capacité réproductive,
et même en tant qu'embryon,
il était déjà une sémence
qui inévitablement se formerait
en tant qu'être humain.
et dès les ventres maternels,
nous considérons la vie
comme une vie sacrée, humaine,
image des dieux.
OK ?
Donc c'est très important
de me rappeler de cette réalité.
Donc,
la motivation suprême
pour l'évangélisation
devrait être celle-ci.
OK ?
Donc là,
une illustration qui me motive beaucoup,
c'est pour plus que
ça puisse devenir difficile
d'aimer l'être humain tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui
dans sa corruption.
L'image,
c'est comme si
ces dessins animés
qui ont une princesse
derrière les dragons
dans un château.
Et la réalité,
c'est que oui,
parfois,
on ne voit qu'à les dragons
chez les êtres humains,
mais nous devons être sûrs
qu'il y a la capacité
de restaurer son image
chez tous les êtres humains
et que même si aujourd'hui,
ils manifestent leur pire version
et leur pire action,
ils restent image de Dieu
avec le potentiel
d'être comme Christ.
Donc,
Paul,
il était là
en train d'exercer
un rôle officiel
pour approuver
la mort d'Étienne.
OK ?
Et Paul était sauvé
et est devenu
le grand Paul.
Donc,
s'il y a eu de l'espoir
pour lui,
il y a de l'espoir
pour tous.
Et donc,
c'est sur l'image de Dieu
qu'on devrait baser
cet espoir évangélistique,
cet amour
envers l'évangélisation
pour que l'homme
revienne à être
comme il était un jour
et qu'il restaure
l'image de Dieu
davantage dans sa vie.
Ensuite,
une autre discussion
qui est intéressante,
c'est
dans quel lieu biblique
nous devons
définir l'image de Dieu,
nous concentrer
pour comprendre
l'image de Dieu.
Donc,
ça,
c'est une question
très intéressante
quand on étudie
l'histoire de l'Église
car il y a eu
des positions
différentes
et divergences
tous les longs
de l'histoire de l'Église,
dès les pères de l'Église,
dès la patristique.
Et donc,
c'est intéressant
de remarquer.
Certains vont dire
que c'est surtout
la création
avant la chute.
Donc,
c'est clair
que c'est là
où nous trouverons
les passages
les plus riches.
pour d'autres,
c'est
à la création
avant
et après la chute,
car c'est intéressant
car même après la chute,
si la Bible insiste
qu'ils sont encore
l'image de Dieu,
il faut observer
parce qu'il n'est pas perdu
dans l'être humain
après la chute
que nous pouvons trouver
des similarités
avec Dieu
et qui va rester
dans l'homme
pour définir
ce qu'il y a
l'image de Dieu
aussi.
Pour certains,
c'est
à la création
attention
envers
l'approbation
donc ça c'est très intéressant
donc il y a
l'arbre
de la connaissance
du bien et du mal
mais il y avait aussi
l'arbre
de la vie
et donc la définition
de ce qui était
l'être humain
dans sa condition originale
c'est comme s'il était
une sémence
parfaite
dans son état
donc une sémence
parfaite
nous savons
qu'elle deviendra
inévitablement
un arbre
plan et glorieux
mais dans tous
ces états
un arbre
qui a une sémence
parfaite
peut être parfaite
peu importe
qu'elle soit
sur l'état
de développement
quelque part
et donc ce qui est clair
c'est que dans les pactes
d'oeuvre
qui Dieu a établi
avec Adam
c'est mystérieux
de savoir
ce qui se passerait
s'il était approuvé
et qu'il serait
permis
de manger
de l'arbre
de la vie
ce qui nous sera
permis
dans la gloire future
ou qui sera
représenté
là-bas
l'arbre de la vie
qui est mentionné aussi
mais la réalité
c'est que Dieu
après la chute
nous empêche
ce qui semble
nous empêcher
de rendre éternel
notre état
de corruption
après la chute
pour nous protéger
Dieu nous empêche
de manger
de l'arbre
de la vie
et nous chasse
du jardin
donc il y a
beaucoup de mystères
mais pour certains
la question est
ok on peut définir
l'image de Dieu
à la création
mais
un vers
ou un imaginant
ce qui pourrait
devenir l'homme
pleinement
en tant qu'image
de Dieu
après son approbation
ok
donc ça c'est
une possibilité
et pour certains
c'est quelque chose
qui rendrait
notre justice
après une obéissance
volontaire
par un test
rendre notre justice
parfaite
nous serions
incapables
de perdre
la justice
parfaite
originale
un état
improuvé
etc
et pour d'autres
les lieux
pour considérer
ce qui serait
l'image de Dieu
au moment
en l'essence
plan
il est
par la contemplation
de l'ensemble
de l'accomplissement
du plan
de rédemption
c'est à dire
c'est comme si Dieu
si on considère
la possibilité
que Dieu
au moment
il nous a créé
à son image
comme la Bible
à plein des textes
qui nous parle
du fait
que Dieu
nous a élus
en Christ
avant la fondation
du monde
et que Christ
a été immolé
avant la fondation
du monde
c'est une possibilité
que l'image
des dieux
dans l'homme
soit basée
sur les Christ
futurs
qui seraient
incarnés
et glorifiés
morts
ressuscités
et glorifiés
donc si par exemple
nous savons
que pour nous
les chrétiens
nous serons
ressuscités
avec Christ
ayant nos corps
glorifiés
si Dieu
n'avait pas
planifié
l'image
de Dieu
dans l'homme
associé
déjà
à ces décrets
liés
à l'envoi
l'incarnation
la glorification
du Christ
donc si on a été
créé
à l'image
du Christ
ressuscité
et donc
ce sont des possibilités
mystérieuses
les plus sûrs
c'est de rester
avec
Génard chapitre 1
à mon avis
mais nous ne pouvons pas
nous empêcher
de réfléchir
de considérer
cette réalité
car la réalité
c'est que nous
aujourd'hui
on est nous
les chrétiens
dans une position
plus privilégiée
et plus élevée
que celle
d'Adam
à la création
même avant la chute
ok
car nous
sommes déjà
unis à Christ
et nous sommes
dans une voie
irrésistible
et inévitable
où nous serons
glorifiés
en Christ
à l'image
de la glorification
du Christ
et donc nous sommes
unis à Christ
de manière inséparable
ce qui n'était pas
les cas
d'Adam
donc Adam était
une créature
très privilégiée
en tant que créature
des dieux
mais nous sommes fait
un enfant des dieux
un Christ
par cette union
après Christ
et donc c'est clair
qu'il parla
on doit toujours penser
ces quatrièmes coins
à garder toujours
une distinction
entre Christ
qui nous est présenté
quand on pense
à cette présentation
des Christ
en hébreu
c'est
les fils
qui est
les reflets
de sa personne
c'est-à-dire
il est l'image
nous sommes la copie
quelque part
et donc il faut
toujours garder
la distinction
entre la douzième
personne
de la trinité
incarnée
ok
donc si Dieu
nous a créés
pourquoi Dieu
nous a interdit
par exemple
dans l'adoration
de faire
des images
l'importance
qu'on voit
en fait
au Sinai
avec les dix
commandements
de nous empêcher
de faire des images
car Dieu
avait déjà
nous fait
en tant qu'image
et nous exerçons
surtout
cette image
des dieux
lorsqu'il nous
participons
dans un culte
d'adoration
de cette
adoration
des dieux
et donc
c'est pas
pour que
on adore
l'homme
bien sûr
que non
on adore
que Dieu
mais la réalité
c'est que
nous n'avons aucun
droit de produire
aucune image
car Dieu
n'a déjà
pas revu
sur l'image
par contre
l'image parfaite
qui doit être
adorée
c'est Dieu
les fils
l'agneau
incarné
et glorifié
et donc
c'est la vision
béatifique du Christ
qu'on verra
et donc
quelque part
l'image
des dieux
suprême
sublime
c'est celle
du Christ
et aucun autre
n'est sera
jamais
cette image
nous allons
grandir
des conformités
des gloires
en gloire
envers lui
mais c'est intéressant
de remarquer
il faut maintenir
cette distinction
par contre
voilà
moi je pense
qu'on ne doit pas
s'empêcher
que même
à la création
les paramètres
auraient pu être
les Christ
qui viendraient
déjà
dans les plans
éternels
des dieux
même si
devant
le développement
du plan
de réunition
nous avons
cette notion
concourte
c'est que
sûr et certain
c'est qu'il y a
des liens
entre toutes
ces présentations
que je fais
car de toute manière
on pourrait aller
dans la direction
de l'art
de la vie
et être
davantage
développé
dans notre
perfection
originale
et rendre
cet état
éternel
c'est qui sera
le cas
quand on sera
glorifié
par les Christ
mais la distinction
particulière
qui est la plus
encourageante
pour nous
c'est que
Adam a eu la foi
et donc il est
avec nous
dans ses bateaux
si on peut dire
comme ça
mais à l'origine
il n'était pas
encore dans cette
position
que nous sommes
car notre image
sera
dans la direction
de Christ
lui-même
est-ce que vous avez
des questions
ici
je vous ai dit
en fait
ce sont des discussions
qui parfois
ne sont pas
conclusives
mais qui nous aident
à comprendre
la gloire du mystère
ok
et donc
je pense qu'il faut
être d'accord
qu'il est plus prudent
c'est surtout
de considérer
la création
et après la chute
où c'est explicite
dans la Bible
mais n'est pas
négliger
ces passages
qui pointent
envers
voilà
cette liaison
dans les plans
des dieux
entre son peuple
élu
avant la fondation
du monde
unis déjà à Christ
et qui va se passer
dans l'histoire
de cette manière
donc Ephésiens 5
Ephésiens chapitre 1
ces mystères
dont par exemple
Paul parle
j'ai fait référence
à Christ
et l'église
on a l'impression
que Dieu a créé
les mariages
les cadres maritales
lorsqu'il a créé
l'homme et la femme
et qu'ensuite
il a utilisé
cette illustration
pour parler
de la relation
du Christ
avec l'église
mais la réalité
c'est l'inverse
c'est que Dieu
a créé
intentionnellement
les cadres maritales
pour illustrer
une réalité supérieure
et précédente
dans la mentalité
des dieux
quelque part
qui était
les mariages
entre Christ
et l'église
vous comprenez
c'est ça
que Paul veut dire
le mystère
en Ephésiens
et donc ça va
un peu
dans la même direction
et donc
dans toutes les phases
de l'église
vous allez retrouver
voilà
cette tension
entre ceux qui veulent
rester
qu'avec Genèse
et après la chute
et ceux qui veulent
réfléchir plus
dans la direction
du Christ
ce qui rendrait
plus facile
l'une des questions
aussi
liée
est-ce que
par exemple
les corps
font ou non
partie
de l'image
des dieux
dans l'homme
ok
c'est une chose
qu'on va parler
après
c'est sûr
et certain
que la vision
chrétienne
du corps
a toujours été
infiniment plus
supérieure
et sublime
vis-à-vis
d'autres religions
qui présentaient
une dichotomie
entre la matière
et les spirituels
etc
et qui mettaient
tellement d'emphase
sur
les portions
spirituelles
par exemple
comme si c'était
les appels
de la chair
tout simplement
qui conduit au péché
avec une conception
de la chair
qui était plutôt
liée au corps
mais la réalité
c'est que selon la Bible
même la chair
n'a pas qu'il
a la connotation
du corps
c'est la chair
spirituelle aussi
et donc c'est important
car la Bible
elle garde les corps
comme quelque chose
de sacré
et donc il y a
deux possibilités
quand on pense au corps
soit
l'image
des dieux
fondée sur Christ
ancrée sur Christ
qui était déjà vue
dans la pensée
des dieux
comme notre médiateur
parfait
tant qu'il est homme
soit
nous pouvons penser
tout simplement
à la fonctionnalité
de l'homme
dans un univers
visible
et donc si Dieu
nous a créés
pour les représenter
dans un univers
visible
nous avons besoin
d'un corps
pour nous manifester
en tant qu'il dieu
et donc dans ce sens là
ces corps
seraient fonctionnellement
un outil
qui est compris
dans la conception
de l'image des dieux
donc à l'image des dieux
Dieu nous en donne
encore de cette manière
je vous donne
je vous présente
les mystères
et les possibilités
ok
ensuite
et peut-être
la direction
dans laquelle
je l'ai pris aussi
mais
et ensuite
on va
on va considérer
ces deux
traitements aussi
dans l'histoire
de l'église
qui ont fait
la distinction
entre
voilà
ça c'est pour
essayer de comprendre
quand on considère
par exemple
avant la chute
après la chute
c'est clair
qu'on doit
reconnaître
des distinctions
par rapport
aux états
de l'image des dieux
et donc par là
ça on va arriver
plus tard
mais
on va se dire
il y a un sens
plus étroit
on considère
l'image des dieux
et un sens
plus large
ok
donc
les sens étroits
c'est plutôt
les sens spirituels
et c'est là
on va considérer
tous ces aspects
moraux
chez l'être
bon
qui on avait
dans
dans la perfection
originale
à l'édan
on était l'image
des dieux
avec cette perfection
cette justice morale
!
qu'on trouve
dans la parole
des dieux
et ensuite
quand on pense
au sens
plus large
plus naturel
c'est ce qui
même après la chute
nous percevons
qui s'est préservé
en nous
donc c'est
par exemple
la capacité
intellectuelle
d'être
une personne
avoir
l'autoconscience
autodétermination
moralité
même si
nous sommes
moralement
imparfaits
et corrompus
nous avons
quand même
un sens
de justice
nous sommes
des êtres
relationnels
des communications
complexes
qui avons
une conscience
sur des
coupabilités
des responsabilités
des rédivabilités
et donc
d'une manière
générale
tout ce qui va
nous distinguer
des animaux
quelque part
c'est le sens
plus large
de l'image
des dieux
dans l'homme
mais dans les sens
plus élevés
plus plan
et étroit
c'est ce qu'on appelle
la justice
l'élément
cultuel
l'adoration
de vrai dieu
et la sainteté
originale
donc
c'est ce qui a été
perdu radicalement
après la chute
donc quand on pense
à cette distinction
aussi
entre les corps
ou non
etc
donc c'est intéressant
Calvin
il est présent
car nous pouvons
nous ne devons pas
supprimer
ou séparer
l'homme
de ce qu'il est
dans son intégralité
dans sa constitution
mais c'est clair
que nous pouvons
faire quelques distinctions
sans séparation
dure
entre là
où les choses
sont plus évidentes
donc c'est clair
que nous cherissons
l'image des dieux
surtout
dans son sens
plus étroit
spirituel
plus élevé
sans tété
mais nous devons
reconnaître
que nous avons
plein de facultés
et capacités
ce qu'est
Dieu
et nous
qui avons
dans la création
et ensuite
c'est la même chose
par rapport au corps
car le corps
est plus lié
au faire
au exprimer
quelque part
mais les capacités
voilà
donc les sièges
de l'image des dieux
et l'âme
on devrait dire
comme ça
je pense que Calvin
a raison à cet égard
mais ça va affecter
tout notre être
et toutes nos facultés
tous nos composants
et donc Calvin
il disait
c'est comme si
l'image des dieux
dans l'âme
c'était
l'âme c'était
le soleil
de l'image des dieux
mais ces rayons
vont se communiquer
sur tout ce qu'il y a
l'être humain
lorsqu'il fonctionne bien
ensuite
il y a cette
cette distinction
entre
structure
et fonction
ok
donc
ça c'est important
car
pour certains
et là
à nouveau
c'est une division
assez dure
et je ne suis pas
en train de plaider
pour cette division
nous allons voir
comment l'ensemble
il est plus important
que ça
mais quand on pense
à la structure
de l'homme
on pense plutôt
à l'essence
de l'homme
c'est qui l'homme est
donc l'homme
il est l'image des dieux
c'est celle
qui est plus important
à garder
mais
l'homme
il fonctionne
comme image des dieux
aussi
donc à nouveau
copie
représentation
donc ce que
nous faisons
quelles sont nos fonctions
l'adoration
les services
la gouvernance
ça
c'est plutôt lié
aux fonctions
de l'homme
l'homme doit fonctionner
comme l'image des dieux
et donc pour certains
historiquement
il y a eu cette distinction
en mettant plus
d'emphase
ou parfois
même en présentant
des divisions
pour certains
qui disaient
non l'homme
il fonctionne
comme image des dieux
et les autres disaient
non l'homme
il est l'image des dieux
et donc la réalité
c'est que l'homme
il est l'image des dieux
et donc
il ne peut pas
ne pas fonctionner
comme image des dieux
vous êtes avec moi ?
donc c'est à dire
c'est inséparable
car quand on revient
à Genèse
on va voir
par exemple
puis Dieu
dit
faisons l'homme
à notre image
selon notre rassemblance
et qu'il domine
sur les poissons de la mer
donc vous voyez
la liaison directe
et qu'il domine
sur les poissons de la mer
donc nous allons les faire
notre image
comme notre rassemblance
et qu'il domine
donc c'est à dire
même la fonctionnalité
des dominés
des représentés
est déjà comprise
directement dans le contexte
pour démontrer
que l'homme
il est l'image des dieux
et il fonctionne
comme image des dieux
donc Dieu créa l'homme
à son image
donc c'est qu'il est
il les créa
à l'image des dieux
hommes et femmes
donc très important pour nous
on va revenir plus tard
mais
la complémentarité
des genres
l'importance
l'homme et la femme
sont égaux en importance
quelque part
ils sont image des dieux
particulièrement chacun
mais ils sont surtout ensemble
en préservant leur distinction
leur rôle
en fonctionnant
par la complémentarité biblique
car ils auront par là
la capacité
d'être l'image des dieux
de manière plus visible
et de fonctionner
comme image des dieux
de manière plus efficace
et donc c'est très important
de préserver
les respects
de la complémentarité
à cet égard
donc ensuite
Dieu les bénit
et Dieu leur dit
soyez féconds
multipliez
remplissez la terre
donc fonction aussi
reproduire la création
de Dieu
c'est Dieu qui a créé
les choses
avec richesse
avec la capacité
de multiplier
et donc soyez féconds
Dieu n'a jamais révoqué
ses commandements
au long de l'histoire
de la rédemption
ni dans le Nouveau Testament
ni dans les pires moments
de l'histoire
d'Israël
donc on va
on va venir
on s'est arrêté
un peu plus tôt
dans l'acte 7
mais la prochaine chose
qu'Étienne va évoquer
dans son serment
c'est qu'ils étaient
esclaves en Égypte
leur vie a été rendue
difficile
donc ils étaient
accablés
par l'exploit
et la difficulté
des vies peut-être
en tant qu'esclaves
en Égypte
et en plus
ils étaient en train
de pratiquer
l'assassinat
de leurs enfants
mais Israël
n'a pas arrêté
de grandir
les plus étaient frappés
les plus avaient
des enfants
et les plus
les plans des dieux
a prospéré
des Genèneses
d'Apocalypse
nous voyons la bataille
contre la multiplication
et particulièrement
la multiplication
du peuple des dieux
et on tombe
dans les mensonges
du diable
à chaque génération
à cet égard
et donc ici
c'est très important
soyez féconds
multipliés
remplissés la terre
et la sujétissés
donc cette capacité
de reproduire
l'image des dieux
ça c'est les privilèges
les plus élevés
des l'être humain
d'avoir la capacité
donc nous
on a été fait
l'image des dieux
c'est la chose
la plus glorieuse
que Dieu a fait
et Dieu nous a donné
les privilèges
de reproduire
des images des dieux
vous voyez
la gloire
de ce qui Dieu
nous donne
comme tâche
de multiplier
et donc à partir de là
dominer les poissons
de la mer
les oiseaux du ciel
tout animal
qui s'émeut
etc
donc fonctionnalité
et être
et donc voilà
on va revenir
sur les détails
de ces textes plus tard
mais c'est juste
pour vous montrer
qu'il y a
cette distinction
au long
de l'histoire
de l'église
mais
je pense
que les positions
les plus glorieuses
les plus équilibrées
c'est celles
qui regroupent
l'homme
en tant qu'image
des dieux
en comprenant
surtout
son suture
ce qu'il est
mais en comprenant
aussi
ses fonctions
d'accord
et donc
quels sont
les arguments
bibliques
les premiers
c'est de vous présenter
l'inséparabilité
d'être
et fonction
en Genèse 1
que nous venons
de lire
1 et 2
mais aussi
dépenser par exemple
à ce qui est
la spiritualité
selon la Bible
donc par exemple
qu'est-ce qui est
la spiritualité
selon surtout
la compréhension réformée
qui a bien
réclamé cette réalité
dans toutes les enfas
donc par exemple
ça va être reflété
dans toutes les enfas
pour l'interaction
avec le monde
ça va être reflété
sur l'enfas
et surtout
les puritans
à toujours préserver
la piété
les relations familiales
et ensuite
les fonctionnements
de la société
donc toujours
préoccupés
avec les fers
et les affections
et les actions
donc ça revient
au schéma
quelle est la règle
d'or
c'est qu'il représente
l'objectif
de l'homme
donc par nos confessions
au catéchisme
prendre plaisir
à Dieu
et les glorifier
ou par la considération
du schéma
écoute Israël
laisser votre vrai Dieu
et le seul vrai Dieu
tu aimeras ton Dieu
dès tout ton cœur
et qu'est-ce que cela veut dire
d'aimer Dieu
de tout ton cœur
de toute ta pensée
de toute ton âme
et de toutes tes forces
et donc la réalité
c'est que l'être humain
a été fait
pour aimer Dieu
et aimer Dieu
comprend
connaître Dieu
avoir des affections
par Dieu
profondes
de toute ma pensée
de toute mon âme
et de tout mon corps
et le corps
c'est cette manière
dont avec nos corps
nous allons glorifier Dieu
par obéissance
en reflétant sa gloire
par mots œuvres
et donc la spiritualité
elle est composée
de ces trois choses
c'est qui sont
les trois facultés
de l'homme principales
les trois composants
essentiels
de l'homme
donc son âme
sa pensée
son corps
et donc là
nous voyons de manière
très claire
que l'homme
il est l'image des dieux
et l'homme
il représente
ou il doit fonctionner
en tant qu'image des dieux
dans la totalité
dans son existence
sans division
ou séparation
donc l'image des dieux
est au cœur
de l'entrephologie biblique
donc on va s'arrêter
ici aujourd'hui
il est au cœur
de l'anthropologie biblique
et c'est là en fait
en considérant
les privilèges
que l'homme a
la responsabilité
la rédivabilité
que l'homme a
d'être l'image des dieux
pour notre bien
pour notre joie
pour satisfaire l'âme
comme dit Augustin
Dieu les a créés pour lui
et l'âme humaine
n'a pas de repos
jusqu'à ce qu'elle
ne se retourne
vers lui
donc là
c'est pour notre bien
mais aussi
pour une question
d'obligation
l'image ne peut pas
refuser
d'imiter
celui
qui l'a fait
à son image
on pense au miroir
à nouveau
donc Schaeffer
il disait
que l'homme devrait
restaurer sa compréhension
de combien corrompu
il est
mais dans la génération
qu'il devrait restaurer aussi
la grandeur
et sa noblesse
donc sa noblesse
ne se trouve pas
dans la satisfaction
de ses perspectives
très égoïstes
à propos de soi-même
très individualiste
mais
un dieu
Calvin
il disait
que pour
voilà
quand il commence
avec
les institutions
de la religion chrétienne
il met son emphase
sur cette conception
qui a été connue
comme les
sensus divinitatis
ou la sémence
des dieux
qui Dieu a mis
dans tous les êtres humains
et il présente
cette relation
c'est impossible
de connaître
à soi-même
sans connaître Dieu
et il donne aussi
la conception
que c'est impossible
de ne pas connaître Dieu
en se connaissant
bien sûr
correctement
donc si on essaye
de comprendre
ce qu'est l'être humain
par sa conscience
sa moralité
on est directement poussé
envers Dieu
bien sûr
c'est la corruption
du coeur humain
qui nous empêche
de connaître Dieu
comme il faut
et voilà pourquoi
on a besoin
de l'oeuvre de Dieu
régénératrice
mais
nous devons plutôt
nous retrouver en Dieu
pour être plus fidèles
à la compréhension
d'Augustin
dans la dynamique
de ses enseignements
sur les confessions
surtout
c'est de nous retrouver
en Dieu
de nous connaître
de nous comprendre
en Dieu
donc c'est pas possible
de perdre
l'image
de Dieu
sans cesser
d'être humain
donc être
être humain
c'est déporter
l'image de Dieu
donc l'homme
n'est pas compréhensible
l'homme n'est pas
explicable
sans Dieu
l'homme est
de soi-même
inexcusable
devant Dieu
de soi-même
inexcusable
devant Dieu
c'est le roman
chapitre 1 à 3
donc
en tant qu'image
nous ne sommes pas
appelés
à être
ce que nous voulons être
ce que nous voudrions être
donc la liberté
selon
la Bible
n'est pas
de donner
elle
à nos imaginations
de ce qu'on aimerait être
un poisson
qui voulait être
un oiseau
s'il sort
de l'eau
il va
s'autodétruire
et c'est pour son mal
qu'il pense pouvoir
changer
de ce qu'il est
homme et femme
Dieu les a créés
c'est destructeur
l'échaînement
de sortir du cadre
de ce que Dieu
nous a créé
pour être
nous avons été créés
pour être l'image des dieux
la satisfaction
de notre existence
sera retrouvée
dans cette voie
et la réalité
c'est que
nous serons quand même
rédévables
si nous réfusions
de les faire
par cette destruction
donc en tant qu'image
c'est Dieu
ce que Dieu veut
est notre volonté
la plus noble
et sa gloire
est notre plus grand bien
ok
c'est comme ça
qu'on doit être
focalisé par la perspective
donc les discussions
préalables
préliminaires
et la prochaine fois
on va considérer
une distinction légitime
entre
les aspects
de l'image des dieux
qui sont plus liés
à la structure
de ce que nous sommes
et les aspects
de l'image des dieux
qui sont plus liés
à notre fonction
et on va considérer
les trois mandats
et
d'entre ces trois mandats
l'importance
de la complémentarité
des genres
l'identité
masculine
féminine
etc
et ensuite
les états
de l'image des dieux
ok